i
yo soy parte de eso
en realidad voy a hablar con propiedad
yo heredé una enfermedad en padre que se
llama hipertensión arterial y que con la
cual conmigo hace muchísimos años porque
él y su familia la padecieron en cambio
mi hermana sufre de los bronquios
y eso lo heredó de mi mamá y ambos
compartimos algunas alergias que nos
molestan de vez en cuando y lo heredamos
de la abuela
yo quiera saber si en el auditorio hay
gente que comparte esto
que ha heredado de su propia familia
dolencias y malestares enfermedad
levanten la mano por favor
levanten la mano sin miedo
bien somos más grandes y si yo les digo
que eso no es cierto o que es
parcialmente cierto
les voy a contar una historia de familia
que es la de mi propia familia y se
remonta 160 años a un pueblito perdido
en la montaña que se llama por el o en
italia y que en la actualidad está en
pie
allí viven de acuerdo al último ascenso
315 personas allí nacieron mis
bisabuelos rafael y matilde que tuvieron
cinco hijos cinco hijos que fueron
inmigrantes todos vinieron a la
argentina
y se radicaron en esta
ellos vinieron en diferentes etapas de
su vida con diferentes edades pero casi
todos detrás de una ilusión corridos por
la guerra las hambrunas ellos tenían una
nueva patria que los estaba esperando
que los iba a cobijar y traían ilusiones
ellos vinieron hacer la américa pero no
la américa que nosotros pensamos hacer
dinero
ellos vinieron detrás de un sueño y una
ilusión y trabajaron trabajaron
muchísimo mi abuelo guillermo
fue peluquero director de 'el correo'
pintor de estancias vendedor ambulante
como todos los gringos que vinieron cada
uno de ellos logró realizar situ su
propia familia en el caso de mi abuelo
se casó con doña margarita tuvo cinco
hijos y catorce nietos
hace dos años nos reunimos 136 de los
más de 500 descendientes directos
que tienen esos cinco inmigrantes y la
verdad que nos conocimos y nos
reconocimos muchos de nosotros que
vivíamos acá jamás habíamos cruzado una
palabra y éramos familia y fue
maravilloso un día de festejo y yo
observaba es decir como nos parecíamos
físicamente y además que bailaban más o
menos parecidos comíamos casi igual nos
reíamos igual y charlamos de todo y
charlamos de enfermedades también
entonces ahí también me di cuenta que
compartíamos varias enfermedades todos
hablamos también de los ausentes donde
estaban mis padres mi papá que murió a
los 57 años víctima de lo que hoy
sabemos que se llama síndrome metabólico
porque tienen una persona obesa
diabético hipertenso que tenía problemas
con las grasas
con el colesterol y tenía problemas con
los platos de comida porque parecía ser
que nunca eran lo suficiente
y mi mamá murió un poco más tarde a los
70 años también como consecuencia de una
época enfermedad pulmonar obstructiva
crónica
ellos vivieron una vida también de
sueños ilusiones llevaron adelante una
familia y finalmente
yo creo que enfermaron y murieron en su
ley por comer demasiado y no adecuado y
ella por no haber podido dejar jamás el
maldito pucho
eso era un estilo de vida no saludable
el que llevaban
yo tengo recuerdos de mi infancia
lindos en mi adolescencia pero también
tengo algunos penosos y tristes lo veo a
mi papá sentado en una reposera en el
patio de mi casa bajo un parral
prácticamente no podía hacer nada estaba
enfermo oa mi mamá ayudándole a subir
ocho peldaños de una escalera para
llegar a su departamento y teníamos que
parar una o dos veces para que tomara
aire
a mí cuando me dicen todos vamos a morir
es cierto no hay novedad
sería interesante tener una película
para saber cómo va a ocurrir eso porque
esta fantasía que de repente estamos acá
y nos vamos le ocurre a muy poca gente
la mayoría de nosotros va a pasar por un
período de declinación de desgaste de
discapacidad y de enfermedad y bueno y
que va a tener una relación directa como
ha sido nuestra vida como la hemos
vivido
desde mediados del siglo 2018 a mediados
del siglo 20 las causas de enfermedad y
muerte en la población eran tres guerras
hambrunas y millones de personas
murieron por estos causas que fueron
todas externas donde el hombre no podía
hacer nada el hombre el ciudadano común
porque se declaraban y se ejecutaban en
otro lado fuera de la posibilidad del
manejo personal
desde mediados del siglo 20 hasta
nuestros días
hemos cambiado nuestros hábitos y
entonces empezamos a comer comida
chatarra además empezamos a fumar
masivamente y empezamos a adquirir
tecnología y divertimentos que nos
permiten estar sentados horas días meses
si quieren sin mover un solo músculo
salvo desde el control remoto también de
alguna manera nos adaptamos a vivir con
el estrés de cada día y eso hizo cambiar
radicalmente las causas de enfermedad y
muerte entonces ahora es decir en estos
tiempos nos enfermamos y morimos de
infartos cardíacos accidentes vasculares
cáncer y accidente en la vía pública la
mayoría de ellos son responsables de un
estilo de vida que hemos adquirido y
sólidamente
la organización mundial de la salud dice
que salud es el completo bienestar
físico psíquico y social y no solamente
la ausencia de enfermedad pero fíjense
esta definición es del año 47 y nunca
más se actualizó tiene 70 años y por qué
pasó eso yo creo que la palabra
bienestar se interpuso como una cuña y
no dejó progresar porque evidentemente
el bienestar es una cuestión casi
individual salvada las necesidades
básicas no es lo mismo en la calidad de
vida de alguien que vive en la montaña u
otro que vive en algún campo vecino o
una persona que vive en una gran ciudad
imagínense lo que pasa si trasplantamos
de un lado a otra esa persona
seguramente empeorará tremendamente su
calidad de vida
entonces nos hemos quedado súper y
marion con esa definición
tampoco tuvo en cuenta la organización
mundial de la salud en esos tiempos que
en realidad la existencia humana tiene
cuatro dimensiones una psíquica una
corporal una espiritual
y finalmente está el entorno es decir
con quienes nos vinculamos y quién nos
vincular
y si esto es como las cuatro patas de
una mesa si nos falla a una la mesa se
cae si nos falla
cualquiera de estas dimensiones caemos
caemos enfermos o podemos llegar a morir
cuando yo fui a la facultad de medicina
me enseñaron que los vivos cómo
funcionaban los vivos a partir de los
muertos entonces yo tenía ahí un cadáver
disecado que estaba quieto con un
profesor que con una pizza levantaba un
músculo y decía este mueve esta
articulación esta vena que lleva la
sangre a tablada yo estaba fascinado
porque me parecía increíble eso esa
máquina perfecta que era material y
además respondía a la teoría del átomo
del átomo de newton
la materia fíjense la fecha que isaac
newton describió esto fue un genio
newton en el año 1600 90 hasta que
aparece la física cuántica no tiene ni
100 años entonces dice no la parte más
chiquita de la materia no es el átomo
hay muchas partículas subatómicas
entonces inventan una diseña en una gran
máquina que reproduce la explosión
inicial que le de origen al universo
entonces tenían razón los científicos
aparecieron millones y millones de
partículas mucho más chiquitas que el
átomo no es de adelanto molar partes más
pequeñas sino que estaban estas
partículas subatómicas la más conocida
se llama bosón de higgs en homenaje al
físico
peter hill y eso se conoció en su
momento como la partícula de dios lo
primero que apareció cuando se inició el
universo yo para imaginarme entonces ya
no tenía una materia sino que estaba
compuesto por partículas que subían y
bajaban y se movían y de repente la
energía
así me imaginé un día estaba en el patio
de mi casa y miré esta nube de mesa que
llama como un niño
o un tornado que en realidad en el
interior que tienen hay agua energía
pero se transforman en una pared es
imposible atravesar los bueno esos somos
nosotros
y ya no soy más una bolsa de huesos y
órganos son partículas ya somos
comunicados con el exterior
permanentemente entonces aprendí esto
del hombre energético el hombre materia
quedó atrás el hombre energético en un
energético este nuevo que yo tenía
frente a mí está integrado al universo
porque definitivamente los átomos y las
partículas son inmortales y son las
mismas que están en el árbol de la calle
en el río en la laguna la montaña agua
acá que los estamos respirando por eso
estamos integrado al universo
y desde el punto de vista médico empecé
a tener otra visión porque yo hacía una
historia clínica biológica y únicamente
creía en lo que veía en lo que podía
documentar
pero me di cuenta con esto que la mayor
parte de la historia está sumergida y no
la vemos y a veces la medicina soslaya
esto no lo tiene en cuenta pone en la
historia biográfica de esa persona que
es lo que siente que es lo que cree que
le va a pasar por qué le pasa eso y en
qué entorno se está moviendo eso es
fundamental entonces ya uno empieza a
tener una mirada holística integral
el 5% y no más de las enfermedades son
genéticas y hereditarias
en realidad de si son tan raras que hay
especialistas y hay institutos que se
dedican exclusivamente a estudiar este
tipo de enfermedad el 95% de las
enfermedades que nosotros padecemos de
alguna manera las hemos adquirido más
allá de que tengamos alguna
predisposición
entonces qué es lo que le damos a parte
del parecido físico los ojos las leyes
mendeliana que estudiamos y todo más
nosotros básicamente heredamos conductas
estilos de vida formas de comer forma de
pensar forma de tomar decisiones
entonces volvemos a recorrer el mismo
camino de las personas a las cuales
copiamos
en el año 2000 se desarrolló
completamente el genoma humano
que es de alguna manera el documento
biológico lo que llevamos cada uno de
nosotros en nuestra sede
los genes los genes son partículas de
energía e información con la cual
venimos al mundo están en cada una de
estas células ya cada una de nuestras
células tiene ese esa patente de genoma
ese genoma puede ser modificado en su
expresión porque miren lo que pasó los
científicos eufóricos dijeron dos cosas
primero debemos tener seis mil genes y
un ratón tiene 30 mil bueno resultó que
no tenemos más de 20 a 24 mil genes
y la segunda es que solamente una parte
de ello de estas barras está en
actividades que hacen fabrican proteínas
para nuestra vida
entonces esto es como ver una ciudad de
noche desde el avión que la mayor parte
está oscura y solamente ilumina dos
avenidas edificios y uno podría desde un
comando apagar algunas luces y encender
otra lo mismo podemos hacer con la
expresión de nuestro género no vamos a
cambiar el genoma pero si los que están
trabajando si yo tengo una
predisposición genética para tener un
cáncer de pulmón y fútbol que crees que
va a pasar y si yo tengo una
predisposición para tener hipertensión y
muerte súbita la acaba comiendo
vegetales verduras y frutas entonces
esto nosotros lo podemos saber ahora
desde la epigenética lo que hacemos de
afuera
ordena nuestros genes y le hace producir
otro tipo de proteínas
también tenemos en cuenta ahora desde la
neurociencia que tenemos 40 60 mil
pensamientos por día y la mitad de ellos
son negativos cuando uno tiene
pensamientos negativos se pone ácido
segrega de anímico orbison que son los
combustibles del estrés
por eso enfermamos y nos desarrollamos
cuáles fueron los desafíos que yo tuve
que enfrentar en toda esta historia
primero alejarme de ese banco que me
estaba esperando debajo de una barra
entonces yo pensé bueno si hago lo mismo
termino igual y bueno empecé a
transformarme a cambiar y a
transformarme a hacer otras cosas a
pensar distinto a tomar otras decisiones
y la parte dura realmente también fue
desafiar los conocimientos que yo había
aprendido
es decir de repente tenía una física
teoría que tenía 400 años tuve que
terminar con esto de estudiar a los
pacientes y decirles a mis enfermos no
tener nada anda al psicólogo dejado
orgánico como si fuesen dos cosas
distintas
la mente y el cuerpo eso es cartesiano
en el dualismo
tiene cuatrocientos años y también fue
difícil enfrentarme con los
conocimientos y mi especialidad lo que
yo he aprendido justamente esto de los
genes mi especialidad hoy está más que
nunca atada nos interesa en la industria
farmacéutica
y a los que fabrican tecnología y por
qué no a los políticos que están más
preocupados por inaugurar hospitales de
alta complejidad en lugar de hacer
circuito de salud y planes preventivos
para que no nos enfermemos
también aprendí que curar no es lo mismo
que sanar una oscura cuando desaparece
el síntoma o la enfermedad y sana cuando
vuelve a tener el equilibrio y la
armonía que perdió equilibrio y armonía
uno está el equilibrio cuando piensa
dice y actúa en consecuencia y está en
armonía pero si cuando entiende esto de
cómo funcionamos con átomos y partículas
entonces estamos armónicos con el
exterior yo me cuido más y cuido mi
universo a mi entorno porque dependo de
él
entonces ahora que ustedes saben esto
tenemos la posibilidad de transformar
ese león que creíamos que tenemos
adentro y que nos va a matar
definitivamente en un plato en una
mascota en una mascota que puede ser
hasta un buen compañero de aventura como
lo es el mío y nos va a acompañar toda
la vida porque nosotros tal vez no
juremos definitivamente una enfermedad
pero si logramos esta transformación tal
vez podamos vivir en equilibrio la
armonía de alguna manera estaremos sano
para finalizar quiero ver quién es de
este auditorio están dispuestos a
transformar ese león en gato a calzarse
las zapatillas y salir a recorrer el
mundo a cambiar la dieta a dejar de
fumar si todavía lo están haciendo a
cambiar los pensamientos tomar otras
decisiones que sean mucho más saludables
y le doy esta receta háganlo ya no el
lunes
[Aplausos]